everybody you know I Manhattan Beach
people are not wearing masks
some people are jogging they're on bikes
here's the thing with the lockdown out
here in Cali it's busting at the seams I
mean people are on the road people are
out there going to the beach people want
out man they've been in their house it
is beautiful weather people spend a lot
of money to live here and they've had
enough does it mean coronaviruses fake
doesn't mean it won't kill you if you
get it doesn't mean that it's not
serious if you get it but people have
had enough domestic violence is
skyrocketing people are just which I'm
somewhat surprised I thought being a
domestic abuser with somewhat a fixed
personality trait like if you beat your
kids you beat your kids
it wasn't contingent upon them being
home more or less like if you hit your
wife you found time to hit your wife
that's what I thought literally that's
what I believed I had no everyone's like
domestic violence is skyrocketing I was
like why I guess people are becoming
domestic abusers during this period of
time I guess stresses are running high
the kids are around and I guess what
happens is every day day in day out the
nagging of the wife the the disrespect
of the kid after a while you start going
I start seeing the real you know limit
of words you start wondering you start
saying yourself you know words are
really not what I need at the moment I
need to give somebody a little reminder
who the boss is now it's not right but
that's happening and it's happening at a
startling how much domestic abuse is
going up it's odd I thought if you were
that guy you were that guy I guess maybe
it's that guy
eating them more and woman 2 I don't
want to be I I want to be inclusive
there are women also beating their
children and probably beating their [ __ ]
husbands and maybe beating their wives I
don't I don't want anyone not I don't
want anyone listening to the show to
think I'm saying that domestic violence
is primarily a man's thing
there's tons of proud women that also
engage in just flogging their family
beating the blood out of their family
when things don't go the way they want
so don't for a minute think I'm only but
it's largely male right I mean there I'm
sure that that's and that's going up
people are upset about that there's
domestic vodkas that's that's the big
conversation they're like the economy
that's the thing that you always bring
up to like the economy we're heading
towards great depression all true by the
way all true I know I you want me to be
positive on the program and I've you
know you know I'll tell you about I had
a good burger today we'll get into that
later it's not all bad but we are
looking at I mean the statistics are not
favorable right so for me to say that I
would be you know lying it's other than
the economy people you know when we talk
about the cost of the lockdown
people bring up suicide and domestic
violence and suicide goes up and I get
that suicide goes up and then also
domestic violence is going to just this
is when you talk with people think oh
they got y'all they go domestic violence
is going to occur and I'm like are you
hitting your tilt like what are you
confessing to me but I guess that's what
happens I'm not doubting it so lockdown
in the beginning I understood hey it's a
new virus we don't know what the [ __ ]
going on I still understand it I still a
dude New York is being ravaged and if
you don't know people in New York you're
not talking to people in New York you're
you're unaware of what's going on
there's people dying I
like 23 year-olds dying and then people
got my facebook but that person at a
pre-existing could do it and I'm like
he's 600 pounds you're on Facebook you
are a pre-existing condition what are
you talking about I got fat people
saying yeah well that guy's probably how
do I beat you what so the idea though
the country is full of pre-existing
conditions you can disagree with the
lockdown or say we overreacted or say
that there's a better way without being
a complete idiot and not realizing that
there's people that are in body bags
okay